okay hello everyone welcome to another
WM language design review part of our
language completeness and consistency
series I see we have a few topics here
yeah Association Constructors should
return the result of the
evaluation
so right now um
Association if you give it something
that's you know not actually a bunch of
rules then it'll evaluate all of the
arguments to see if they become rules
and if it fails then it Returns the
original input
expression
okay right
so um you know Ricardo thinks that it
should return the valuated arguments so
it
should uh so his argument is that it's
and I'm he was invited I'm not sure if
he joined us doesn't look like he's
joined us but basically he thinks that
you know it's sort of easier for error
cheing
and um well this case doesn't look very
compelling to me with Echo but maybe
there are cases that are more
compelling right um I mean I do tend to
think if it if it evaluated them it
might as well show it evaluated them
it's very obscure if it if it evaluates
them it doesn't show that it evaluated
them if you get there is what one
downside with that that it's going to go
and evaluate it again and fail again so
that's that's if what if if if if if you
return association with the evaluated
expression is going to go through the
evaluator again see a different
expression and go and evaluate and go
back to Association fa yeah I guess well
I don't know I mean in I mean we don't
have a mechanism to tag it I mean isn't
associational raw
object no if if if if it constructs an
association if it succeeds in we're
talking about the case when it fails to
construct an associate where it gets
input that's not able to construct an
associ I understand so this is the
invalid flag yeah exactly it's an
invalid thing so I I'm against it for
from the fact
that that it's just going to go through
and evaluate everything again and fail
again and that just seems like a lot of
work we're adding work to show the
evaluat expression and then we're and
then we're going and evaluating again
and failing again well I think that's an
implementation is you I think from the
user point of view it will be better if
the thing if it evaluated show it
evaluated because otherwise people will
be confused because that thing might
have had a big complicated thing in it
has a bunch of side effects the side
effects happen it's like really they did
they happen no it it looks like they
didn't
happen but I I take your point about
implementation and I guess Ricardo is
not here to make his case but if if
that's what we're talking
about
in I mean you're saying these other
cases like and don't have this issue
that they are uh you know item potent in
some
sense right they
change right so right and will attempt
to get to true or false and you know
well once it knows it's false it knows
it can
stop right um well I I take Ricardo's
point I think it might be slightly
better but there's this implementation
issue and I think that that probably
blocks it for the time being sorry that
implementation issue was just a
performance issue that it would go
through the evaluator again and if it's
invalid
you know then does it
matter that's a good point that's say
that again if it's an error case if it's
an error Branch anyway does it
matter that's a fair
point I mean this is not a success
Branch right although it's also not
necessarily a failure Branch because you
know consider the case of you know
Association of blank it's pretty weird
it's not that weird Association of blank
is not a weird useful
yeah yeah I just don't see a compelling
case for having it evaluated well I'm
I'm telling you the case the point is
it's obscure to people that it does
evaluate but it doesn't show you it
evaluate it we don't have other examples
of that we don't have other examples of
things that I at least I'm not thinking
of one that reach in evaluate and then
don't admit
it uh well we we have we have those
three examples and the gray bullet
points
um and I don't know if that's deliberate
or which one these ones here yes you
know I don't know if that's deliberate
or an accident of implementation no wait
a minute so those do do the thing that
that Ricardo is proposing that
Association does no the these do the
thing
of uh um evaluating their arguments but
then if it's a failure
case uh you know returning
unevaluated oh boy well I mean clearly
we need some consistency
here here let me
uh see if I
can't
um hey I have a question for you design
oriented folk here there was a function
that we invented I think you might have
been involved about a year ago that
allows you to store a collection of of
bites and tag it as being oh these
collection of bittes represents a
JPEG we invented that for some kind of
import situation
maybe XML related I'm not sure do you
remember what it
is
um boy uh it was more than a year ago
but I do know what you're talking about
and can I reconstruct the name
um and
[Music]
uh you know this it was a year ago I I
think I think it was imported object
oh that's right and it was in
2020 so
uh well you know with the whole pandemic
thing yes just seems like no time's
passed why is this so slow why is that
why was that so slow is our node here
was why was that so slow our node is not
here okay so record that moment in this
in this video show it to him please it's
a problem for
14 am I making
sense I typed the name I want to see the
output immediately
not not in seven
years
um okay this is the thing okay can you
um uh Julio needs to know about this
it's come up for a um
machine learning
application could somebody communicate
that to him should I do it I I can take
care of that
okay this is an interesting construct in
my
opinion
um it's a useful construct for various
various purposes I think he he needed it
for some communication to multimodal
llms okay
uh right so basically Ricardo's argument
is that you
know if if you know if you have some
blob that you expect will be you know
have some side effects and produce and
um uh you know and produce an
association if something goes
wrong um and and then you might and some
piece of code processes that result then
you might run those side effects a
second
time um I just I mean the argu another
argument is I don't want something that
walks and talks like an association but
clearly isn't
one I mean it's sort of interesting that
that doesn't give a
message why doesn't
it probably the pattern case you you
could use whole pattern of course but
right I mean Association of blank should
not give a message no it shouldn't give
a message but that doesn't mean
Association of one comma three does
given that we it's now we've now
admitted that we are looking at these
things it's not like it's just passing
them and saying it's not a rule go
away see what I'm saying I the message
based on number of
arguments well we could just give a red
red carrot based on that number of
arguments
and I think I think we could give a
message saying this isn't a valid
Association so what about Association of
one that's not a valid
Association an association of blank
is okay I can't justify that very well I
can because you know if the thing
couldn't have a rule it's not a valid
Association I can't do look up on that
last thing it's not it's not very
associated no no no I I understand but
it could be a rule in the
co-substitution world of that thing
which we still haven't really developed
and that that's a future thing to do the
whole theory of you know substitution
and co-substitution and so on of what
could be you know that that thing could
be a rule it could stand for a
rule whereas Association one could not
stand for
rule I'm sorry did you claim that there
is some argument counting reason that
there should be a red carot or something
there because I I didn't follow that at
all wait a minute is it's that oh no
association I I I I never Association
does not take a list association takes a
sequence of rules I mean it will also
accept the list but yeah well okay I use
it in the list form always okay fine
forget my argument counting argument
yeah I look without without Ricardo here
I don't think we can make this case any
further I don't think this is a very
important Corner case I think I I I do
take the point I think Jeremy made here
that um this is an error case and so if
it does have to redo the evaluation in
this case it's not
disastrous but I don't have a strong
feeling about this but we need
consistency with these other things and
I don't understand that okay so let's
see evaluation
object
what the heck is the end
there what is N I think that's
probably like the kernel number or
something I'm not sure is it what is
this piece of incredibly bad
documentation well it's something
written by Roman so what do you
expect I'm sorry but this has to be
better this is just inadequate
um just totally
inadequate okay so so somebody needs to
deal with that
please how could this have been there
since version seven with something as
pathetic as that in
there as you don't take a close look at
what Roman is
doing
oh
apparently not adequately so yeah I
can't believe this is that
old yeah I mean I think the formatting
changed a few versions ago uh although
okay can can somebody please push this
and get something less sloppy but let's
go on with our agenda
okay um right so
you had this sort of two-part suggest of
being able to set history length um at a
notebook
level um which you know I think the
implementation might require a bit of
thought but you know that's you know
just like you can sell set the context
and context path um to be notebook
specific or cell group specific you know
I does this mean that the history length
is notebook is specific I don't
understand it because the history is a
single thread in the kernel
uh it's it's not technically a single
thread in some cases I I don't know
anything about this proposal but it is
already the case that we track history
separately in different cell
contexts so if you have
two ISO you know context isolated
notebooks they will not share history
with one another
do you mean outs will be different in
each of them that's exactly what I mean
yes right the Dos work this way WR like
go into that documentation notebook and
you know evaluate one one cell in one
example and then refer to percent one in
the other example and and and and the
way this is done I mean you know it's
kind of Fairly naive uh because I don't
think anything more is really required
which is just that you know we take the
you know as we're switching context we
take the current value of in in string
out and there might be something else
I'm forgetting and we just uh uh shove
them off someplace where they can be
gotten back again later uh and then uh
replace them with the values of the
incoming cell context all right so let's
talk about what that means for history
length so that
means in this notebook what would it
look like here wait a minute addition to
percent
by the way what has happened to percent
modernization didn't make it into 40
hyper
architecture what does that mean but you
you you can't drop a project on my group
that consumes 50% of the time and then
expect all the other projects to proceed
smoothly is it proceeding percent
modernization it requires a lot of my
direct attention my direct attention has
been focused in other places which are
considered important I mean it's you
know I think percent mization is pretty
important is it is it more important
than hyper
architecture I don't know no probably
not I mean depending assuming get that's
what it comes down to you
know we have lots of things that we
consider very important and it's you
know decisions have to be
made I wish I'd known that that was
being paused we really need a better
mechanism for that I mean that's a thing
that's on the global project list it
went from being in progress to paused is
that
correct well I didn't officially hit the
pause button but I did you know produce
a road map which had a pretty optimistic
notion of our ability to make progress
by you know I didn't take it off the
road map but frankly you know other
things on the road map really need to
get on with it we really need to get on
with it we really can't have it just
languish
you know I actually have to make
decisions on the ground about how time
is spent I understand I understand but I
I would like to hear about and and and
and you know I I mean I mean I can't
just
torpedo other parts of the company that
are depending on my group to do stuff I
understand I understand well okay
separate discussion we should talk about
I mean I would liked to hear about this
because it was something I thought was
going to happen and I didn't pay
attention for 140
all right in any
case this question
here I mean the the issue here is do we
store the out because there are plenty
of cases where we just don't
care doesn't matter whether the out you
know whether the stuff in the output is
stored
like it isn't like what by the
colonel sorry where we don't care sorry
okay a giant piece of Graphics was
produced we will never refer to the
graphics with percent we produced that
Graphics only for the sake of displaying
it on the screen is can you really say
that though I mean no I you can't
possibly mean that oh you're right
you're
right
right and so okay but I mean okay so
what is the issue
here right
so well go ahead so right so all right
so the starting point of all this was
you know uh when when you're doing
really memory intensive things like fem
then you know it's it's quite common to
you know set dollar history length to
zero and uh okay this was because Oliver
who may or may not be here was doing
that in his documentation which really
upset me yes and and so why was he doing
it again can you explain that to
me there's two two reasons one is to
make sure that the reference count of
object that's produced is uniquely owned
by the symbol to which it's reference so
the out doesn't add a second reference
because then you can work if you do
things incrementally then on that object
you're working on a unique object that's
a total hack you don't need to make a
copy of it yeah okay that's a total hack
it may be but we don't have an
alternative it's a total hack okay so we
need to talk about wait wait wait you're
you're saying that the automatic memory
management of the kernel is a total hack
no I'm saying that the that way of
avoiding it is a total hack if if the
issue
is okay if the issue is that you want to
modify you have x equals giant
expression right and then you want to
say x equals a new expression and you
don't want the old value of x hanging
around well I understand that that it
might be hanging around because it was
connected out 17 exactly that's ex
exactly right and you don't want that so
this is exactly the case that I was
describing where you want the output of
x equals BL up big giant thing and you
don't want that big giant thing attached
to the out symbol yeah that's the case
we were describing somebody just said
was a stupid
case we said that the graphic that just
saying you would that particular example
wasn't wasn't wise but there might be
other ones I mean here you've you've
assigned it to X in the example
previously you said it was only
referenced by Inn out or whatever so
that if you remove the in and out
there's no way to reference it think
slightly different
yes that's what I was understanding you
to say I see I see I see I see I see so
so so I mean one case here would be the
thing has been attached to something
yeah and so and we know that because we
can know
that and then the question is do you
also attach it to the out
thing and there's the possibility then
of saying I mean I I think both cases
are of some interest right where you
know even if you can't refer to it
programmatically it might just be I've
certainly done things where I'm spewing
out giant collections of things where
all I want is their appearance in the
notebook I will never ever refer to them
they are it's like print output
basically see what I'm saying I'm not
going to refer to print output and I
can't in fact so in other words I'm
using my outlines like print output
yep should there be a a wrapper you know
slash slash don't attach to out yeah
that's an interesting idea that's that's
a bit
cleaner you know don't store on out yeah
it's it's kind of like a quiet except it
isn't quiet I think that's that's that's
implementable and sort of one issue what
one
issue right and you know one issue that
people run into at least naive users is
that you know they think that adding a
semicolon is equivalent to that but that
merely suppresses output it doesn't
remove the uh you know doesn't actually
remove the ass okay but look the case we
care about is the thing's a
gigabyte right which is a case we can
detect I mean we just don't care if the
thing is you know 100 kilobytes or
something we just don't care that it's
being
stored we do care if the thing's a
gigabyte
well so that opens up another
possibility we have uh you know for
front end output we have an output size
limiter yeah we have the output limiter
which is very successful yeah one could
imagine a similar approach to limiting
uh whether or not something gets
assigned to the down values of out why
not and then and then have the output
there if you looked at the down value of
out it would be an output limiter
basically it would be a size limiter
but you wouldn't be able to you know
retrieve the real
thing
would yeah it would have to be a size
limiter that is you that can't be fully
expanded well but but but the way to do
it would be if it's on an outline there
was an inline you could you could have
snared in the inline or at least you
know that no look no here's the point
here's the point you know it was it came
from out 17 if you really want to know
what's going on reevaluate in
17 assuming that there's that's assuming
no State change yeah I understand there
might be State change but but I mean I
don't think that's the
um I think that's you know nothing's
going to be perfect here but at least
you don't blow yourself up with multi-
gigabyte objects okay so we got two two
ideas on the table one is a
slash slash don't
store
um uh what the heck should that be
called
um
suppress I I would call it no out yeah
out I would hate to suggest without
out
yes as opposed to without so to
speak which it's just totally confusing
um uh let me see
um what's the don't include type
word um
exclude what's that exclude out but
that's too
[Music]
weird skip out uh
avoid skip out is better but then know
that suggested like a a kangaroo or
something um
suppress out but we're not really
suppressing it we're suppressing this
we're not we're not we're not we're not
um no it's it it would still display it
just wouldn't have it wouldn't attach
the
out well then it's history suppress
history
well that's suggest that's Global that's
scary how about
that well history
avoid
ahistoric um
Paleolithic yeah block block out G block
history yeah
Amnesia counterfactual
no it's a different meaning Block in our
yeah it
ISU yeah ephimeral
no no no because none of that that stuff
we we don't want to we just want to make
it clear that it's
just I mean given that we have dollar
history
length no history
seems so you would still see the thing
could still see it
right so you could do semicolons SL
slash avoid
history that sounds like you chose
French
[Laughter]
instead so what's the difference between
you know SL slash you know name we
haven't come up with yet and SL SL
print other than the type of the cell is
different uh well you you the print
doesn't get the output size limiter so
that's doesn't it no no actually if you
did print it would still store the
history I think no it doesn't no because
it it'll I think it would I think it
would I think last value would sorry
this is getting into real hackery I
think you'll find it
does where no I'm pretty sure ENT is
null in that case I'm about to check
it think
so I I thought it was only compound
expression which means I think do print
semicolon put put a semicolon in there
in the print Fu put a semicolon in there
after the print Fu in no inside the
print but that's not going to print
anything then but then it will bar no
now now put
bar inside
inside yeah put bar there now and now
look at
percent yeah there you
go
whoa yeah this is how this is the last
value hackery we
have
wow that's really
Paleolithic sure I mean that came from
version one that came from tele printer
type
stuff so
T that's
wild that is yeah I guess I I just
assume that you know so so why doesn't
the print Fu case because because last
value if you did a semic bug hackery do
a semicolon print F then percent would
be
a right now percent should be a yeah it
is that's really weird yeah it is
probably I mean that that that I
understand that right that's the that's
the last value thing it's the fact that
the compounded expression is inside of
the print so I would have thought that
you know it would the print maybe we
should maybe compound expression at the
top level should be treated differently
but I I don't know if I thought that
through oh that's just weird that's just
weird yeah he weird I think it's this is
a bug which has been there for 35 years
I was going to say the number of people
that that behavior surprised and the set
of that people is
impressive it didn't surprise me no but
you were the exception Tom everybody
else you know each time
mark But it surprised everybody else on
the
planet well I think that that suggests
that I think we should look at changing
this okay but let let's go back to the
question
about okay first
point
um what about the possibility let's say
you generate a huge
output okay huge out this thing is going
to be huge
okay
what if there was a
ux let's
see let's imagine generate an out the
two things one you might generate an
output size limiter in the front end
which could then have some extra you
know blobs on it and two you might not
generate an output limiter because the
thing might just be a summary blob of
some kind but it's a me it's a gigabyte
in size and then we could extrude some
kind of uh you know what I'm thinking is
some kind of
ux that says we're huge evaluates to
some kind of summary box for example but
then underneath the summary box there's
a little blue thing that says this you
know same thing that we do elsewhere
this wasn't
stored you know do you want to store
it see what I'm
saying this is actually not a stupid
idea in my oh yeah but well what I don't
understand it okay so let me explain so
let's say we do a let's say we do one of
these you don't want to have to use a UI
every time you do a finite element
operation no you don't touch the UI okay
here's here's what would happen Okay so
so you see this okay full store full
expression in Notebook okay so now let's
imagine in this case here right that it
said in addition that not stored in
out4 well I can't say that because the
only reason the store full expression or
even the show more and show less buttons
work is precisely because it was stored
in out of I understand that but so then
let's imagine that you blew out of both
the output size limiter and the storage
size limiter okay then what I'm
suggesting is that this footer here
would then say something
different and if you put a semicolon
there you suddenly start seeing a UI
that's pretty weird well I don't think
it's that weird I don't think
it's I understand I understand what
you're saying I understand what you're
saying we're dealing with okay we we're
dealing with multiple okay I don't think
it's a bad solution so can we walk
through this please for a second okay so
let's imagine that you hit the um out
size limiter okay then what this would
say is you wouldn't have these options
you would just see the visual
here which is pretty inadequate like
what's the point well okay so the more
common case
is that you would see something which is
a blob here you wouldn't hit the output
size
limiter you would just see a blob let's
let's import a blob of some kind here
okay and then underneath the
blob it would say
uh you
know this blob was is is not connected
to the out so the way to do that I think
would be to to change what the out looks
like perhaps yes that's the obvious
thing to do and then if you don't like
that you press you
know the out looks looks different and
it
says and maybe there's a plus underneath
the out which you can go to to try and
to ask to re-evaluate and store
it another possibility
guys in fact this might be the best
possibility is you do store it right
when it's
generated
okay but you put it into a essentially a
circular buffer where it goes away if
you didn't say store it now you lost
your chance and when out 15 is generated
it's gone
see what I'm saying based on
size yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this
only happens if it's huge right so this
is like dollar history length of five or
something based on
size so if you exceed that you delete
the last five you know the last one that
yes yes that's fine yeah I agree I agree
that that that is what that's like or
dollar history like the one or something
for this something like that yeah it's a
it's a dollar history
length so you can use okay I understand
what you're saying that that's not a bad
idea so list crazy than this UI thing no
no wait a second wait a second they're
both sensible okay so the idea would be
there's two dollar history lengths okay
one is that applies to all expressions
and the other is one that ex
applies either only to Expressions above
some size or there's a history length
that is based on the total size of the
out Expressions rather than a a length
as in the number of out Expressions it's
based on the total size of the out
Expressions am I making
sense well that that means you would
have to compute the B count of every
single out which which we're not doing
right now yes and is potentially
expensive
okay well but I mean wait a minute wait
wait a second the one thing that isn't
expensive is is it bigger than x because
you go and you start recursing and by
the time it's bigger than x you say it's
bigger than
x right the thing had turned out to be
five are we are we already measuring the
size of every output with the size
limiter yeah but there might be a
semicolon here so
no we're measuring the the the outputs
size in boxes not in yes yes sorry sorry
my bad but we don't we don't apply the
output limiter if it's null or or or or
it's like a default thing no sure we
don't I mean this the output limiter has
other sorts of rules like Graphics don't
count yeah yeah okay so so let's talk
about this case okay so what I like
quite a bit is something either it's a
if it was implementable it would be this
if it gets bigger than I mean maybe
there's a single expression size
limit okay at which the thing is stored
only
temporarily I think that's okay I I
that's not crazy okay but fine but and
whether that's stored in a buffer of a
circular buffer of size five or what I
don't know but my suggestion is when
that happened when it isn't actually
attached out 14 the out 14 fuzzes out in
some way visually yeah fine and and it
gives you the chance it has a UI element
that gives you the chance to say no no
no no no I really want this store
it before it's gone before before it's
gone yes once it's gone it's gone right
once it once it you know exited the
circular buffer it's
gone I like this solution okay so I I
guess so I have uh two questions one so
the the the history length and the and
the
size the size limit or whatever is we
want to call it are those global are
those per notebook possibly both I'm not
sure but but hold on let me ask a
question the output size limiter how is
that controllable is there a Dollar
variable that controls dollar output
size limit okay by the way can also be
set via the preferences yeah there a
option but the front end option
basically just works by setting that
kernel
Global okay all right
so this
then okay so we would have a similar
thing to that for a storage
limit for
expressions and when the storage limit
is exceeded we need to design here this
thing you know like like what happens
when it goes you know out of blank out
of dot when the thing is no longer
stored when you reopen The Notebook it's
something a bit like that it's it's
something where the thing looks I don't
know maybe it goes a gray color and it
falls over in
italics like it died type thing and then
it has a little plus underneath
it see what I'm
saying and then you press the plus it
gives you a UI the UI says store this
expression permanently um and it also
gives you the possibility of going to
settings to change that setting
overall okay now the question is the
setting do you want that on a per
notebook basis and I don't think we care
terribly I mean well that's
easy okay uh I mean do we care do walk
me through that I mean is you know is it
because so well I guess the question is
do do uh you know are are you going to
freak out when you know
Oliver you know sets this at the
beginning of his
documentation what the this this uh you
know should need to because whatever to
he won't need to I don't think I mean
what are we going to set it to what what
value are we going to set this to 50
megabytes what value are we going to set
it
to
um well
I 100
megabytes um I I think it should be
relatively large um
and well okay let's say okay let's look
at
this okay so I've got 56 gigabytes in
principle go ahead do you believe that
number
uh I'm not sure how much I believe that
number I mean the problem is what does
memory available even mean in modern
operating system I know I know I know I
mean it gives some rough order magnitude
this isn't a tiny machine you know I
know it's not a tiny
machine
um given that amount of memory
available maybe saying half a gigabyte
is not unreasonable well I don't
know what what do you guys think what do
you think what would you want it set to
well I would I would want to keep this
at Infinity because you know I don't
want to lose things and you know uh yeah
I I mean frankly I was thinking not for
myself but for you Stephen if uh I don't
know how much you rely on percent when
you're doing like your huge multi-way
graph experiments yeah I do rely on
percent so i' probably want this set to
Infinity okay so that means we probably
have to do it on a notebook by notebook
basis that it's setable in the
stylesheet
okay so how would that work what would
John how would that work well we could
certainly set it uniformly for all uh
documentation notebooks uh and and that
might be a very reasonable thing to
do
right fine the only the only thing that
could possibly break would be examples
that relied on percent and you know we
can uh we can we can check for that yeah
to see if there are any outliers we
should be aware
of all right the other qu the other
question is um if you are in a
standalone
kernel then a is this applicable and B
is there you know is there a way to say
expose facto oh I actually do want to uh
save that in app I don't think it's
terribly applicable I think this is say
notebook story I
think well let me think about this for a
second well you could still have the no
you can still have the variable it just
says don't store this you know dollar
whatever and you wouldn't set it by
default you know by default just like
dollar history length it would be set to
Infinity yeah exactly yeah okay and if
if
we're and then we don't have any
mechanism for adding it to out if you if
you want to save the if the last out is
bigger than you expected then you need
to say x equals perc in order to correct
going away yeah okay well x equals the
thing originally not percent because
percent doesn't store anything because
it got I see so so it's not actually in
percent right it's no no no you you
could do x equals percent so long as
percent still there words we we'd allow
the circular buffer mechanism yeah in
the in the pure kernel yeah it it it'll
work similar to okay what are we going
to call the variable that is the um size
limiter
here what is the variable called I think
dollar history size limit yeah why
not I mean we have history element size
limits
History either history element or
history entry size limit as opposed to
out toze limit which is probably too
obscure well it's called history Lane so
it should be parallel
to entry sounds like it's you know an
exit Entry Way type thing okay yeah I I
would be okay with history
element all right yeah and then we'll
have a corresponding front end option
which is just that without the dollar
sign same way as we do for output size
limit and
well the other question is what happens
if you have percent so sorry not percent
you end with the semicolon so there's no
out in in the I see so you don't see it
right I think we need some kind of
indicator that's a ux thing that's part
of the ux design
okay
uh yeah cuz that case is even a bit more
Insidious is you don't even see it and
then it's goes and you thought it was
there but then it goes
away so let's just see John what what um
let's say I say
um well we already
obscure the out label in the case where
the kernel session is
gone
um well we obscure it but look there is
no out label here so the question is
where is the handle well get it and the
end labels too we also do the end labels
with a dot yeah yeah uh we need decorate
and and and in the output size limiter
we also uh do that which you can see if
you just want to you know quit and then
start a fresh kernel and you'll see some
things update in the
notebook
um and there you can see the output size
limit are
changed yep and of course all the in and
outs okay this needs some design I don't
know what it is okay I mean it probably
needs some kind of
some kind of little X or something below
the in label that indicates that the out
disappeared or I don't know what we'll
have to we'll have to figure that out
yeah and and it should be said that
right now the front end doesn't have a
good way of being notified by the
colonel that these sorts of changes
happen um the uh I mean it might it
might be nice for example if we could
EST establish oh say a dependency on
out2 and in the same way that we you
know in Dynamic you know we can
establish a dependency on X and the
colonel lets us know if x changes but
that same trick does not work for
checking a specific down
value it's a thing that people have
asked for but I assume it's probably
hard uh on the colel side Tom
Tom
Tom so sorry I missed that the the idea
of in the same way that we can have the
colonel notify the front end if x
changes but what about uh x with a you
know what about a specific down value
what if can we uh imagine a world where
the front end could say colonel notify
me if out of two
changes well if it was specifically just
for out then I mean obviously this this
is the the colonel would have a
mechanism for you know clearing things
so it would notify the front end when it
does that okay well I mean you know
that's I mean it's not a general
mechanism for any down value but but it
would work for this right okay well yes
I mean there are two sorts of ways what
yes if if you're suggesting to provide a
specialized thing that would be great I
was sort of you know uh needling in for
the possibility of a Down value specific
notification because lots of people have
requested that sort of thing um I don't
really understand what that means in
general other than just it means other
than just not the symbol but it means
the symbol with its you know
argument yeah I'm still still a bit hazy
about that okay can we dispatch okay
this rounding radius thing seems to me
the obvious thing to do is to allow an
association
syntax which is syx is okay what's that
I I I mean I mean this syntax is uh with
one minor exception that I realized
earlier today this except this syntax is
copying syntax that is used in many
places for front-end options uh and we
have talked about using Association
syntax but we we we don't have a place
to even begin there is no precedent for
doing this sort of thing well there is
plenty of precedent in the kernel I mean
this would be rounding radius Arrow you
know right but but associations mean
something different
in in the front end they they they
changed the
inheritance well it let's let's actually
let's set that aside for the moment uh
no I'm saying rounding radius goes to
this that would be how I would expect
this to look in a kernel
situation um the well that makes no
sense right I mean what is the default
value for unspecified
Corners Z
look what if you want to specify default
value I suppose I assume that we can do
this let me just try it I assume I can
say left Arrow 15 left AR 15 top AR
50 well I think that'll work
yeah no but why is it different from
this oh Stephen think about
iters the the top left corner and that's
saying make the left oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh silly me okay now I understand
what the syntax
is right I mean I think a more in right
and see I don't know what what what what
what you did is supposed to mean well I
guess you use the same but if you made
no no no I was confused I was confused
don't worry about it I was
confused this syntax is perfectly
reasonable and kind of
cute right I mean I think the one
interesting question is do you have to
specify the the five and if you leave it
out does it default to zero or does it
default to something from the
environment I think here it's defaulting
to zero which seems reasonable to
me John I asked
youa yes I mean the fact that
this the fact that this works is
probably a bit accidental but yes cool
but but but yes I you know we can make
sure that it officially supports and
documents you know that it supports
defaulting to zero uh I'm not
fundamentally opposed to that I I I I
didn't write it in my first draft of
documentation because it's not how other
similar options have worked but I agree
that it's a sensible sort of thing to
want I think this is very cool I think
it's useful I think that well I mean
it's it's it's definitely useful because
this is the only way without using like
nine patches or something like that that
you can assemble pieces of a thing
together that have that has a rounded
rectangle around you know the the the
element as a whole we have nine patch
right what is it called oh it it's uh we
have nine patch but it's it's not
documented really yeah we use it all
over the place but well
because because
in order for it to make sense we would
also need functions that can construct
nine patches for you or interpret nine
patches for you I mean there's there's
like an ecosystem that would be required
and I just haven't had the energy to put
together that EOS just give the patches
in the nine patch or do you have to give
a bunch of other stuff a a a nine
patch uh has inside the bit map it has
uh you know basically uh the edges of
the bit map en code what the patches are
yeah and that has to be done in a
particular way if it's not done right
then it's not an N patch anymore it's
just a bit
map I
see and I I mean it's not insane you
know I'm I'm I'm you know this would be
totally the sort of thing like we could
could be you know an intern project or a
summer school project or something but
it's just as we talked about earlier
with priorities I can't justify why
isn't that going to the image processing
team isn't it for them to generate a bit
map that is appropriate to be a nine
patch like for example could we not
import an image and make it a nine pack
well I I I think it's entirely
reasonable for an image processing team
to do uh
yeah but Mo most of this I mean let me
be clear it's you know the functionality
is not exotic most of this is just about
designing the functions themselves not
implementation is easy it's the design I
understand so can we can we ask the
image processing team to take a look at
it because I I my prediction is that
this is really something that ends up
being something where you take an image
and you want to nine patch ify it that's
exactly right or on the other hand you
might want to take an existing nine
patch and and understand what it means
how it splits up and maybe modify it in
some way yeah I get it I get it I think
we should give that to the image
processing
team yeah that's fine uh but but my
earlier point being that you know if you
if you're trying to throw a rounded
rectangle around a uh you know uh you
know composite things that fit together
side by side uh that doing something
like this may be your only option right
and it's nice okay let's just move on to
the last item here sequence alignment
this is a pretty simple issue so I think
right so basically right you can
sequence alignment lists and you can
sequence alignment strings and you can
sequence alignment lists of lists but
once you do that the output becomes
ambiguous because you'll notice that in
the first one I'm aligning a thing with
itself so there's perfect alignment and
in the second C input I'm aligning two
different things and I'm producing
identical
output um so you can sort of distinguish
between a list denoting a difference in
the list that's simply a common argument
to the two lists um so the solution
would be to add a second argument or I
guess a third argument to sequence
alignment that's the head to use for the
differences so then that second output
you could say rule or something like
that and the if you said rule then it
would show those things not with pairs
of lists but with a with a rule
yep okay my only con concern here is and
I don't know if anybody from the biology
team has been contacted about this I I
don't know how much tentacle you know
how many octopod you know how many more
tentacles are needed for sequence
alignment you see what I'm saying I I
don't know whether there are other
things that aren't options for example
why on Earth is merge differences not a
link that seems like a bug in
documentation well either there are no
examples or it it seems like a bug so we
should get it
fixed combine adjacent
differences my only question here is
whether the head should come as the
first argument as an optional first
argument that's two questions one
multiple sequence alignment which I
don't understand very well and whether
this need might need to be
verogs and therefore this would need to
be an
option and two whether this should be be
a a preh head rather than a post head
okay probably it can be a post head just
like distribut and things like that of
post
heads but can we please talk to the
biology team and make sure they are not
oh we are about to enhance sequence
alignment to have 17 new
arguments okay so that would be Michael
start with Michael okay it's not
specifically him who's dealing with this
function but he will know okay
yeah and and and right this came
precisely because Lou was looking at
three-way diff and that's when he
realized this ambiguity and therefore
could not use sequence alignment for for
three-way
diff
so ouch well okay
fine um I mean is there an option that
we could use that would represent this
head thing I it seems more natural as an
argument this thing really is a firmly
to argument object
um I mean we have functions which sort
of wrap a hold in certain cases and so
on right and and in those cases it's I
think it's almost always an argument an
argument the the one is there any case
where it
isn't there in arguments options it's a
element of an association so so there's
a string key but not a
symbol okay all right well then let's
assume okay I'll check with Michael and
if assuming we don't anticipate another
argument then we can all right sounds
good okay anything else guys nope okay
thanks a lot see you later
bye